and there's also exotic meats and hot
dogs or like if you go to a worst kosher
like these exotic sausage flavor there's
rabbit there's a lot pinion there's duck
there snake there's all that stuff
snake hot dogs make hot dogs again
wouldn't it just be a snake hey there my
name is Edward and I'm Nate I'm destiny
hi I'm Michelle and today we're gonna be
guessing sheep versus which one's a hot
dog I don't know if I'll be able to tell
what's cheap and what's expensive right
cuz we were talking earlier like what is
an expensive hot dog and does it have
like truffles and gold flake on like
what's a cheap hot dog I imagine it was
something bad beyond saying yes I'm just
an all-around guy I get creative with it
I do go with the only thing I go
everything I do mayo mustard ketchup
relish that whenever I do the Dodger
dogs over at the Dodger Stadium
I go bacon wrap bacon rest like the best
one with like some onions on it true
yeah grilled the onions or you keep it
off cause you got a grill you gotta do
oh my god it's a hotdog toaster I didn't
even realize this was a requirement oh
it's cool I've never seen a hotdog
toaster before although okay in all
honesty I to be honest I am love this
look I mean it reminds me a pleasant
build of that old tell them about the
movie you know that feels of the what is
it 56 yeah retro I like it I don't
understand it but I'm here for it right
so we both beat our face I have lashes
you have lashes those are fresh lashes I
see you girl I see you alright my actual
[Music]
whip our hands in the toaster this is
the bun
okay I got a hot dog it's like no condom
is just a regular light saber fight but
with hot dogs I like that it's beefy
beefy in texture like an osprey plane
yeah I think this is the normal hot dog
I get like dogs I just go grab an Oscar
Mayer and keep it pushin taste tastes
like regular yeah I'd say that one was
pretty dang cheap yeah it definitely
feels cheap I got to check out the other
three to really put it down my spectrum
on for now yeah definitely on the on the
bottom Pole hopefully the others are
better oh hey this
we're but this reminds me of like
childhood this is like when you're
little and you know you're just eating
the hotdog with the barbecue and yeah
fancy hotdogs like it's just a summer
barbecue yeah good old dirty dog the
first hot dog was fine I mean it tasted
like home tasted like regular everyday
occupier yeah I thought about us yelled
like one time like maybe 6.5 yeah that's
seen it for the next one we have okay
okay you know what
I don't know about this texture I don't
think that this is like know what this
tastes like Vienna sausages mmm I don't
like the flavors very funky it's smoky
there's there's something it hits you
when you inhale it
alright I don't know something about it
makes me feel like it's not me it's like
a meat substitute because it's so it's
so chewy I'd say this one's at least
this one's middle but I can see it also
being the most expensive one it does
taste fancier because I feel like it's
got more flavoring like you can tell
that there's like more spice more
seasoning in it but I like it you know I
want my basic hotdog yeah you know you
go like Trader Joe's and you buy like a
$20 box of hotdogs and you're like I
don't like these at all yeah I'm gonna
say this is more expensive than the
first one really yeah I mean I guess I
can Akamai really just because I think
like I think what makes this expensive
is that because it's chewy
it's either some kind of like fancier
meat and we just got more seasoning I
think that's probably something like I
know yeah Italian flavoring so I feel
like it has to be more expensive than
like a normal hot dog I see the
possibility of being them most expensive
but it's just a taste like it shouldn't
be that expense
because in just the flavor sucks yeah
it's so bad
sorry whoever made that hot dog like Oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
get it this one's a lot bigger yeah oh
yeah oh wait this one's massive I think
I grabbed something extra I don't know
if I'm supposed to eat this part over
there okay
oh yeah she's a big one oh my god this
one I feel the the wrap on the end and I
know that you know a hotdog connoisseur
pretty much knows about the snap when
you're biting into a hotdog
so you're thrown out a lot of hotdog
terminology at me right now I think I'm
out of my level okay you hunted this
just tastes like a really thick Oscar
Mayer our dog I'm gonna touch my wrap
wait you got plastic would you just say
let me touch my wrap I mean I will I
feel like the texture bit is more what
I'm used to because it was like a normal
hot dog and not like super chewy like
the hotdog number two yeah that's how
they stuff it I think in the old polish
air of times or something you like
legitimately know a hot dogs are made I
believe I might be speaking out of
Wikipedia page and just thinking there's
some aftertaste in it
Rome vibe I do think if I were to have
this look like a bun and ketchup and
mustard and whatever others copy me want
this will be a fine dog yeah I agree I
do like this one better this one is
pretty tasty mm-hmm
mine didn't have like plastic covering
the whole thing like yours do so I think
I got the better hot dog no judgment
though yeah I'm gonna go this is more
expensive for the simple fact that it's
so much larger such curves over here and
there's also exotic meats and hot dogs
or like if you go to a worst kosher um
like these exotic sausage flavor there's
rabbit there's a lot Pena there's dog
there snake there's all that stuff snake
hotdog snake on toxic wouldn't that just
be a snake hotdog number two was so
weird yeah this has to be an expensive
hot dogs I've never had there was so
much like you said seasoning from it
where I was like these other two were
just like you're the meat obrigado folks
have you even man great question we're
supposed to be like a hot dog expert
what is this also did I break the
toaster I think an order of cheap too
expensive I think hotdog number one is
cheapest
I think hotdog number three uh-huh
diggity thick friend is gonna be like
mid care and then I think hotdog number
two is the most expensive I think the
first one was the cheapest and then I
think this one's the most expensive and
then the middle one I think is the
middle one
oh god yeah I'm gonna go with that
because I don't think we would get the
hotdogs in the order that they are
otherwise I would have went one was
cheapest two was the seconds here and
three is the most expensive first one is
definitely cheapest the second one we
tried out is
let's put in the most expensive because
it was the tastiest thing that wrapped
its premium quality there and that's
this last one I would say it's in the
second level of seconds here yes $32
okay okay that's where they like
massaged the cows making like really
soft you guess what you get to keep the
toaster I always wanted one of these
thank you thank you
I consider myself what we need champagne
now
[Music]